bonjour et bienvenue dans europe hebdo
au parlement européen ici à bruxelles
dans cette émission on s'intéressera à
la violence faite aux femmes en europe
nous irons en finlande l'un des pays où
le nombre de décès est le plus important
et cette semaine alors que le monde
entier a les yeux tournés vers l'egypte
et vers la tunisie
la voix de l'europe est inaudible à
leurs questions catherine ashton est
elle en train de manquer une occasion
historique de faire exister l'europe sur
la scène internationale
dans les couloirs de bruxelles on
l'appelle la femme invisible
il ya un an lorsque catherine ashton a
pris la tête de la diplomatie européenne
la presse tire à boulet rouge sur cette
baronne inexpérimentés et totalement
inconnu pour représenter l'europe
elle a demandé à être jugé sur pièce
dont acte
un an après elle n'en finit plus de
faire ses preuves et c'est au tour des
capitales européennes de s'agacer
inexistante transparente absentéistes on
l'attend sur le terrain en haïti elle
passe ses week-ends à londres l'europe
de la sécurité de la défense aucun
intérêt mais alors que le monde arabe
est balayée par un vent de démocratie à
bruxelles enfant elle s'exprime et
appelle à une transition il ya plus de
démocratie en egypte un an après sa
nomination lady ashton est aujourd'hui à
la tête du plus gros service
diplomatique du monde 3650
fonctionnaires cent trente six ans
bastad un réseau supérieur à celui des
occasions mais pourtant l'union
européenne premier contributeur
financier dans les territoires
palestiniens en haïti lors du
tremblement de terre ou dans les pays en
voie de développement est souvent le bon
dernier dans l'action diplomatique
alors à l'heure où la diplomatie est
encore l'apanage des états à quoi donc
sert madame ashton et la diplomatie
européenne
voilà une question posée par nora hamadi
joseph daul bonjour bonjour merci de
nous avoir rejoints vous êtes
eurodéputés français vous êtes surtout
le président du groupe ppe ici au
parlement européen c'est le plus grand
groupe politique dans l'hémicycle quand
on voit ce qu'on dit aujourd'hui à
bruxelles de catherine ashton est-ce
qu'on a raison de la critique ainsi mais
je crois que l'athletic
j'ai moi même je les critiques elles
n'étaient pas assez réactifs par exemple
à haïti sur le sujet c'est vrai que ce
service doit être beaucoup plus présents
et beaucoup plus efficace
d'un autre côté je voudrais aussi dire
que mon ami pendant un an la mise en
place de ce service les directeurs
généraux tout ça c'est arrivé que le 1er
janvier donc mais la réactivité il est
essentiel que dans l'est dans le
prochain mois où les prochains deux mois
ce service parle au nom de l'europe
mais ce qui l'est pas déjà trop tard est
ce que l'europe a déjà manqué l'occasion
d'exister sur scène internationale
finalement on a manqué probablement sur
beaucoup de points sur la scène
internationale et avec ce qui est en
cours que ce soit au niveau de l'egypte
et tout le bassin méditerranéen
l'europe doit être présent et ce qui est
grave c'est que si on n'est pas présent
au niveau communautaire
on est obligé d'être présent au niveau
pays par pays et qu'est ce qu'on
représente pays par pays par rapport au
reste du monde
d'autant qu'en plus la diplomatie est
comme le reste la halle et comme la
nature elle a horreur du vide donc on
voit si c'est pas l'europe
c'est par exemple ce sont les états unis
la qui prennent la main par exemple sur
logique ce sont des états unis ou alors
ce sont les différents pays qui font des
lettres qui disent trois pays qu'à pays
cinq pays et au niveau communautaire
c'est très mauvais c'est ça du tout
autre ça moi je suis totalement contre
il faut que l'europe réagissent d'une
seule voix nous sommes 500 millions de
concitoyens
l'europe doit avoir sa diplomatie mais
est-ce que catherine ashton pour revenir
un peu à elle clairement est ce que
c'est un problème de fonctionnement
c'est à dire que l'europe ne pourra
jamais parler d'une seule voix ou
clairement est-ce qu'on a un problème de
casting
moi je crois que c'est un problème de
c'est pas facile de parler d'une seule
voix au niveau des 27 ça je le conçois
je le lis tous les jours mais il faut
quelqu'un qui prenne
je dirais la poignée qui commencent à
avancer à se faire voir à y aller il
faut aller en egypte il faut aller au
niveau de tout ce qui est la tunisie il
faut là essayer d'avoir le roc doit être
présent pour mettre en place la
démocratie la vraie pour qu'on n'ait pas
un jour ce qui s'est passé en iran on
est passé d'une extrême à l'autre
extrême c'est ça qu'il faut éviter
il faut maintenant aider ces pays là à
ce que la démocratie se met efficacement
en place alors en europe
l'europe a un rôle important à jouer
parmi les critiques qui sont formulées à
l'encontre de critiques de catherine
ashton il y a aussi le fait qu'on dit
finalement elle ne défend que les
intérêts britanniques vous partagez ces
critiques écoutez non non je ne serai
pas je serai pas aussi méchant que dire
non je crois qu'elle a besoin maintenant
de son service qu'ils soient présents
dans les vrais événements
et puis qu'après elle même elle fasse
une autre communication est ce que le
parlement européen des moyens d'action
est ce que vous vous pouvez influent est
ce que vous pouvez faire remonter le
mécontentement des députés européens sur
la diplomatie ont péri ce que je suis en
train de faire je vais encore le faire
cet après midi pour faire un appel au
conseil en dix ans au conseil il faut il
faut parler d'une loi européenne
donc il faut mettre en place ce service
pour qu'il fonctionne alors il ya un
autre sujet d'actualité toujours sûr je
lirai l'actualité internationale
c'est l'entrée ou non de la bulgarie et
de la roumanie dans l'espace schengen
est là la france a une position avec
l'allemagne une position assez forte en
gros la france et l'allemagne 10 non est
ce que vous partagez cette position non
je ne partage pas j'attends le rapport
puisque ne l'avons pas encore le conseil
nous apprend quand vous voyez le rapport
au niveau du parlement donc que pour le
moment il est demi secrets mais vous
savez tous les confidentialités qui a là
dessus on va la voir gelée demandé
officiellement ce matin au nom du ppe
qu'on est le rapport pour qu'on puisse
l'analyser
après avoir fait l'analyse de ce rapport
la seule chose que je dis il ya des
règles à respecter pour schengen si
elles sont respectées
le parlement doit voter pour celle ne
sont pas respectées on doit le dire et
on doit donner les dates pour qu'il soit
respecté et recontrôler mais nous ne
pouvons pas rajouté systématiquement
d'autres faits ou d'autres demandes
supplémentaires qui n'ont pas été
demandées à d'autres pays mais il faut
rester juste mais quand la france dit
ces pays ne sont pas prêts à entrer dans
schengen et en gros schengen c'est déjà
un espace où la houle et où les
délinquants et les voleurs peuvent
rentrer sans problème
est ce que vous êtes d'accord est ce que
ces deux pays ne sont pas prêts pour
entrer dans schengen il ya encore des
problèmes techniques
disons le très clairement sur les
frontières terrestres j'étais moi même
en roumanie la semaine dernière j'ai
discuté avec les différents ministres
ministres le président basescu
il y a encore des problèmes à certains
endroits entre la frontière entre la
bulgarie et la roumanie
la roumanie la bulgarie encore des
problèmes de frontières au niveau de la
turquie ça il fait ça c'est des
problèmes techniques
s'ils sont pas réglés ils peuvent pas
rentrer et ils le savent mais d'accord
là dessus
la la les problèmes techniques qui sont
posées qui doivent être respectées
doivent être respectés et quel est selon
vous l'explication de cette position si
dure de la france
mais vous savez les positions d'urs
avant de rentrer ça me dérange pas ça
oblige à o2 aux deux cas de se mettre
d'accord de voir la réalité comme vous
l'avez dit j'étais en albanie pour le
problème des visas
il ya quelques temps on m'a expliqué que
toute façon les albanais comme vous
dites le grand banditisme et tout ça ils
n'ont pas besoin de visa ils sont déjà
là au glauque qui avec si on donne pas
de visas on bloque les étudiants
bloquent les gens qui ont envie de
travailler honnêtement en europe
tous les autres sont de toute façon déjà
parti alors moi j'ai proposé la chose
suivante pour les albanais et au
président au président berisha gély
alors il faut mettre par exemple un
contre un
si on reçoit ou si on constate qu'il ya
des gens qui n'ont pas le vrai visage
donc ils les reprennent mais ce que vous
dites là par exemple on peut pas
imaginer que nicolas sarkozy ou que
laurent wauquiez affaires européennes ce
ne soit pas au courant de ça donc c'est
quoi c'est une posture politique écouter
de toute façon on à vis des choses qui
étaient fausses c'est à dire les données
sur schengen sont disponibles et ont
permis à la roumanie depuis le mois de
septembre
arrêté 200 personnes au niveau des
mafias du grand banditisme
c'est grâce aux données schengen donc
ils les ont pour pouvoir travailler avec
donc ça ça existe
donc là il faut qu'on se remette à table
quand on discute sur 1
donc pour que la france dit la vérité il
faut encore il faut rediscuter
sereinement poser les bonnes questions
avoir les bonnes réponses et puis
prendre la bonne décision et là où on
voit qu'un député européen même si les
français peuvent avoir une position
évidemment différente que celle du
gouvernement français mon rôle de
président du ppe
merci beaucoup et j'applique toujours ce
que dit le président de la république
fait juste merci joseph daul d'avoir
accepté notre invitation on va rester
dans l'actualité internationale avec
comme chaque semaine un tour d'horizon
des télévisions aux européennes nous
serons rejoints dans un instant ici même
par une correspondante de la télévision
polonaise elle est très concerné par la
situation en hongrie et au bélarus voici
donc un florilège d'image sur ces deux
sujets rassemblés par six sites fixes
haut le président biélorusse a été
interdit de déplacement dans l'union
européenne
l'europe qui fait la police et qui
sanctionne la biélorussie mais pas
seulement
sa première cible fut la hongrie
critiqué pour la loi sur les médias
alors qu'elle vient à peine de prendre
la présidence de l'union
le premier ministre ban a été vivement
critiquée au parlement européen à cause
de la loi hongroise sur les médias qui
impliquait la réhabilitation de la
censure sans sur le mot est fort et les
journalistes sont allés vérifier auprès
des rédactions hongroise le journal le
plus important de hongrie nesta patcher
liberté populaire est sorti le 1er
janvier avec en titre une phrase écrite
dans les 27 membres de l'union la
liberté de la presse est morte ça donne
est ce que la présidence de l'union est
en sécurité entre les mondes landry
alors en sécurité avec la hongrie à la
tête de l'europe pas si sûr pour sept
députés m oui à l'irak simple est ce que
monsieur rebelles pourra vraiment
intervenir sur des questions de droits
de l'homme comme par exemple en
biélorussie il ya encore des journées
en prison suite aux manifestations after
alors nous sommes à présent avec
magdalena taddeo chaque bonjour bonjour
alors vous êtes ici à bruxelles l'une
des correspondants de la télévision
publique polonaise
est ce que ces deux sujets qu'on vient
de voir est ce que ce sont des sujets
que la tvp a traité a bien sûr ce sont
des sujets très importants dans la
presse et dans la télévision polonaise
nous avons même envoyé des envoyés
spéciaux justement hongrie et la russie
pour suivre les événements des élections
présidentielles angora aussi mais aussi
la nouvelle loi médiatique et tout ce
qui ce qui a suivi en hongrie mais les
sciences et les sentiments sont s'il
s'agit de la loi médiatique les
sentiments au pologne sont plus mitigés
que je dirais en leur qualité de ce
qu'on vient de voir dans l'eure dans le
reportage où on parle de censure vous
êtes plus prudents parce que nous sommes
plus prudents
quoique bien sûr il ya une partie des
médias et des commentateurs qui dit
aussi sur le cadenas à la liberté de la
presse bien sûr mais nous allons
travailler notre travaillons déjà avec
le gouvernement hongrois c'est la
présidence polonaise justement après la
présidence hongroise le gouvernement il
a choisi cette position justement mitigé
de ne peut-être de ne pas froisser les
l'endroit parce que nous avons besoin
d'eux et la position de notre
gouvernement c'est nous allons voir
notre position après la décision de la
commission européenne ça c'est la
position je dirais officiel que qu'en
pensent les journalistes polonais est ce
que
il ya une inquiétude par rapport à ce
qui se passe en hongrie ou au contraire
finalement ce n'est pas si grave que ça
oui bien sûr il ya une sorte
d'inquiétude mais ça dépend aussi des
médias s'ils sont de gauche ou de droite
la position est différente
il y a là une partie de la presse qui se
révèle un petit peu hystérique qui
justement vad instant ce sens qu'on a vu
dans le reportage c'est le cadenas c'est
l'attentât à la liberté de la presse
il y avait même la lettre du rédacteur
en chef de la gazette a admis cnic qui
était d'un grand posant acquis qu'il a
écrit avec l'ex président de la
république tchèque vaclav havel avec
l'ex président de la république
hongroise aussi pendant deux pages
justement c'était une lettre ouverte à
tous les intellectuels polonais euros
perd contre cette loi
par contre il ya des nouvelles lettres
en pologne de la presse aussi pour que
les hongrois soit ferme koki soir
eux-mêmes pour qu'ils restent avec le
gouvernement pour qu'il se divise pas
donc vous voyez vraiment les sentiments
sont très mitigés le débat mais
l'inquiétude persiste parce que ça peut
nous arriver à nous aussi s quel
sentiment en pologne
comme en hongrie un petit peu que encore
une fois les pays fondateurs de l'europe
les grands pays entre guillemets de
l'europe serait une nouvelle fois en
train de donner des leçons aux autres
tout à fait justement et je pense que
justement ce sentiment mitigé
anvers est ses appels ses alertes comme
quoi c'est l'attentât à la liberté de la
presse
je pense que là une partie de la presse
polonaise est très prudente parce que
justement ça vient des anciens pays de
l'europe et on a ce sentiment que ce nom
de de nouveau les anciens pays
ceux qui sont bien installés bien ancrée
qui se permettent de nouveau appelé à la
raison les nouveaux pays comme si voilà
les numéros il était non pas si
raisonnable que les anciens sur yon nous
un peu arrogant par exemple les français
ça c'est un autre débat moi je dirais il
y avait en cologne beaucoup mais
un certain temps justement ce sentiment
que les français surtout i
pardon en sorte d'arrogance qui n'est
pas acceptable surtout parce que la
pologne et la france il ya beaucoup de
liens historiques d'amitié etc
mais je pense que c'est du passé on
traite pas on regarde beaucoup vers la
france
on regarde ce qu'ils proposent le
président français ont regardé ce qu'il
propose l'allemagne aussi parce que ce
sont deux grands pays qui gouvernent
quand même l'europe
donc il n'ya plus de ce sentiment d'
arrogance mais on a aussi ce petit
sentiment oui les anciens veulent de nos
bons nous montrer qu'ils sont plus sages
que nous merci en tout cas magdalena
taddeo chaque d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors il ya des phénomènes
qui sont malheureusement répandue
partout en europe et les violences
conjugales en font partie avant de
retrouver kathia gilder et son invité
voici un reportage en finlande
il est signé thomas raguet
là
balance des coudes pour femmes j'écoute
bonsoir oui que vous est-il arrivé
un appel dans la nuit finlandaise à
l'autre bout du fil une femme victime de
violence conjugale dans ce centre
d'appels anonymes des psychothérapeutes
comme anna lena se relaie pour
conseiller les victimes nous ne seront
pas autorisés à écouter la conversation
insultes menaces privation de liberté
dépendance financière
la violence est multiforme et bien
souvent elle devient physique
beaucoup de femmes qui subissent des
violences sexuelles craignent pour leur
vie
elles ne savent pas jusqu'où leur
agressé avec un poème d'aléas
mais elles savent qu'elles évidence il
veut leur faire du mal
sato
la finlande et ses six millions
d'habitants est un cas à part en europe
si les violences conjugales n'y sont pas
supérieurs que chez ses voisins
le taux de mortalité lui y est deux fois
plus important
en cause la forte consommation d'alcool
mais aussi un manque de prise de
conscience des pouvoirs publics
traditionnellement en finlande l'état ne
s'occupe pas trop de vie privée la
priorité des travailleurs sociaux et de
protéger les victimes en les dirigeant
vers des foyers spécialisés comme celui
ci caméras de surveillance hortefeux
fermée à clé systématiquement tout est
fait pour rassurer et isoler les clients
comme on les appelle ici là nous entrons
dans le foyer
s'il se passe quelque chose ici on
appuie sur un bouton et la police est là
en quelques minutes
en 2009 près de 350 femmes et enfants
sont passés par ce foyer financé par la
ville
j'ai un journaliste avec moi il prend
des images mais je ne veux absolument
pas qu'il vous file
là encore nous ne seront pas autorisés à
filmer les victimes
une règle absolue pour les préserver des
victimes qui après un séjour de deux
mois maximum retourne auprès de leurs
conjoints ou bleues font le choix de
quitter le domicile conjugal
il est très courant qu'une femme
retourne chez elle et que les violences
reprennent mais elle pourra revenir on
l'aidera autant de fois que vous pouvez
commencer une nouvelle vie sans violence
pour le reste de votre vie
cela demande beaucoup de travail mais
c'est possible
selon carla grenland la spirale de la
violence s dans 60% des cas des centres
des coupes pour hommes violents existe
aussi
il travaille en lien étroit avec les
foyers pour femmes afin d'entrer en
contact avec les maris une particularité
finlandaise les animateurs des deux
organisations se rencontrent donc
seulement pour aborder les nouveaux cas
séméga reste à voir quel genre de
violence y at-il eu des violences
physiques plutôt brutale des histoires
de jalousie
rester en contact sur ce dossier pour
que ce test est sous l'os animateur au
centre pour hommes violents
ce travail croisé est essentiel mais il
est long et coûteux et ses environs
s'est passé à la à la maison il faut il
faut traiter la femme les enfants
l'homme aussi fort il faut essayer de
l'aider dans son projet de changement
etc
il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'argent qui est dit par un coup
financier
un coût social aussi le centre mise donc
sur la prévention et prévoit déjà une
campagne d'envergure au sein de l'armée
pour sensibiliser un maximum de jeunes
hommes finlandais
au niveau national le gouvernement a
lancé récemment un plan d'action contre
les violences conjugales avec pour
objectif numéro un la prévention mais
pour mina puisse pas la responsable du
projet il reste beaucoup à faire pour
faire évoluer les mentalités dans ce
pays qui a pris conscience tardivement
du problème et cela nous aiderait
beaucoup nous qui travaillons contre les
violences conjugales en finlande
si nous avions des conventions
internationales ou des lois européennes
pour nous aider à travailler et à faire
pression sur les leaders et les faire
bouger davantage
cela nous serait utile 4 à 6 millions
d'euros annuels seront investis dans les
cinq prochaines années mais pour les
professionnels du secteur des lois plus
protectrices sont aussi nécessaires et
par conséquent un sursaut de la classe
politique finlandaise
voilà pour ce reportage de thomas raguet
réalisé en finlande sur un sujet très
sensible on en parle avec juan lopez
aguilar bonjour vous êtes député
européen espagnol président et si au
parlement européen de la commission
justice et liberté intérieure et ancien
ministre de la justice espagnole alors
votre réaction d'abord à ce reportage
est ce que ça vous étonne de voir ce
genre de comportement dans un pays du
nord comme la finlande
c'est bon à savoir et comprendre qu'est
la violence contre les femmes la
violence sur les femmes c'est pas un
problème mais dit arrêt à la
méditerranée on sait pas son problème
dans certains pays et qui n'existait pas
dans d'autres pays on compte réellement
113,7 un problème plutôt universel il
faut prendre conscience et pour réagir
au niveau européen il s'agit exactement
de ça et le parlement européen a fait
son travail a lancé l'initiative
concernant la protection des victimes
des délits violents et particulièrement
la violence sur la fin mais on va
reparler dans un instant mais d'abord
pour réagir à ce reportage est ce que
selon vous la finlande est un cas à part
ou surtout est ce que ça vous ça vous
choque de voir secours des de tels
comportements violents
aucun pays c'est un pays à part
les problèmes de la violence sur les
femmes c'est un problème je dis plutôt
universel greeters universel et en
espagne on l'a compris et en espagne il
faut savoir que quand on lançait les
stratégies sur la violence contre les
femmes
on n'est pas les pas d'un problème
espagnol on n'est pas là d'un problème
qui est plutôt universel ministre est
très engagé au niveau européen mais
l'espagne était quand même
l'espagne a été le votre pays a été le
premier à se doter d'une loi pour lutter
contre ces violences alors comment les
votre pays on est arrivé là alors même
que dans d'autres n'a toujours pas une
telle loi est ce qu'il ya une prise de
conscience particulière c'est fait et
j'en suis fier on a remporté les
élections en 2004 le parti socialiste
j'ai fait les ministres de la justice et
on a on a accompli un engagement les
premières projet de loi qui a été lancé
au parlement et les premières loi qui a
été adopté par les parlements dans la
première législature de gouvernement
socialiste sous la présidence de patera
à est exactement la loi entérale contre
la violence sur les femmes
il ya un chapitre il ya eu des débats il
y a il les débats mais il faudrait faire
ça il faut les enragés sur les plans
éducatif sur le plan de l'image de la
femme social et sur les plans aussi de
la protection de la femme contre
victimes de la violence sexuelle de la
violence conjugale de la violence
familiale d'aviation alors c'est ce qu'a
fait l'espagne comme etat-membre voyons
maintenant ce que peut faire l'europe
dans ce domaine essentiel c'est le sens
de la question qu'on vous pose écouter
alors la réflexion réparties de la même
organisation ici en fallait que je parle
aux femmes alors irina on va vous poser
la question a finement d'accord bonjour
est ce que vous pensez qu'on peut
espérer voir un jour une politique
européenne unifiée en matière de
violence conjugale
au lieu de voir comme c'est le cas
aujourd'hui des législations spécifiques
dans chaque état voilà la réponse est
oui absolument nécessaire alors on fait
s'occuper de ce problème les états
membres où l'europe l'autre les états
membres l europe l europe
en fait on a lancé l'initiative du
parlement européen sous présidence
espagnole il ya il à dire un film de
protection des victimes
avec un chapitre dédié et spécialement à
la protection de la femme comme victimes
de la violence conjugale de la violence
sexuelle
il faut pas seulement protéger la
victime au niveau national il faut
protéger la victime dans un espace de
libre circulation des personnes comme
citoyenne et européens la femme a le
droit de se déplacer avec la protection
au niveau européen et une protection
homogène comme victimes de délits à
niveau européen soutient cette prise de
conscience concrètement où on est cette
directive que vous avez contribué à
faire apprendre où on est parlement a
adopté favorablement les rappeurs
maintenant on attend le travail des
conseils sous l'initiative de la
commission
la vice présidente de la commission
chargée des libertés justice et droits
fondamentaux
madame reding s'engageait à lancer une
initiative de la commission qui doivent
être être discuté et je suis dans les
parlements
j'espère plus tôt possible dans la
présidence courant j'espère qu'il y aura
l'initiative il y aura le débat au
parlement européen alors mais
concrètement qu'est ce qu'il ya dans
cette initiative et ce qui est des
mesures très concrètes est ce que par
exemple l'idée de mettre un bracelet sur
sur les conjoints violents comme c'est à
l'étude actuellement en france est ce
que cette idée fera partie des
propositions bien géré mais pas
seulement
il faut établir un mécanisme homogène
des protection policière
un dispositif des réactions policières
des alarmes policière quand il y à
l'appel téléphonique de la femme qui est
en danger d'être agressés pour des
raisons de violence des violences
sexuelles
il faut homogénéiser les dispositifs de
protection
il faut établir un ordre judiciaire qui
soit et exécutif au niveau européen
céline actuellement puisque chaque
chasseur pour me le dise à vous de
penser que sur cette question
les états membres peuvent parler d'une
voix unie avancer ensemble
il faut et des scooters bien sûr je
crois que chaque fois qu'ils ont fait
pour établir une conscience homogène au
niveau européen que ça c'est pas un
problème de l'espagne de l'italie de la
france pas sans problème de l'escadre
navy pas son poulain de la femme a un
problème qu'il doit être engagée à
niveau européen ça comprendre aussi les
pays qui sont occupées les mois parce
qu'ils y allaient pays maintenant donc
dans lesquelles les libéraux des
protections c'est extrêmement déficient
et bien merci beaucoup à vous juan lopez
aguilar d'avoir réagi sur le plateau d'
europe hebdo et chaque semaine et bien
l'europe est au bout du fil question
aujourd'hui de caroline damien nous
sommes retraités nous souhaitons nous
installer en espagne pouvons nous le
faire librement ou y at il des
formalités à accomplir
voici la réponse d'europe direct burqa
rallye oui en fait un temps que citoyen
européenne à la retraite vous savez le
droit d'inviter n'importe où dans
l'union européenne nous toucherait même
votre raquette française du 5 fu comment
prouver que vous savez des ressources
suffisantes et que vous savez une
assurance-maladie complète en ce qui
concerne les formalités faut
s'enregistrer absolument auprès des
autorités nationales espagnoles
et vous pouvez vous aussi posez votre
question au 00 800 6 7 8 9 10 11 appels
gratuits partout en europe et c'est donc
la fin de cette émission à la semaine
prochaine sur les chaînes parlementaires
et merci à tous de votre fidélité
j'ai envie